CARLSON IS NEXT.
♪♪ ♪♪
>> WELCOME TO A SPECIAL EDITION
OF TUCKER CARLSON.
>> Tucker: THE THING ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE IS IT'S SERIOUS
STUFF.
VERY SERIOUS.
IT'S NOT LIKE THE FRIVOLOUS
CONCERNS THAT FILL YOUR DAYS
LIKE PAYING YOUR BILLS OR
KEEPING YOUR MARRIAGE TOGETHER
OR PUTTING YOUR KIDS THROUGH
SCHOOL OR FIGHTING CANCER.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS BIGGER THAN
THAT.
WAY BIGGER.
IT'S ABOUT SAVING THE EARTH.
IT'S ABOUT TAKING ON WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO CALL AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT TO HUMANITY.
A BIG DEAL.
NOBODY UNDERSTANDS THE GRAVITY
OF CLIMATE CHANGE WITH THE
SOUL-SEARING IRN TEBSITY OF
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ.
SHE TALKS ABOUT THE GREEN NEW
DEAL THAT WILL SAVE US FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE.
SHE LOOKS LIKE SHE BZ TO CRY OR
YELL OR BOTH.
WHY WOULDN'T SHE IT'S SCARY AS
HELL.
TIME IS RUNNING OUT.
>> THE WORLD IS GOING ON END IN
12 YEARS IF WE DON'T ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE.
LIKE, THIS IS THE WAR, THIS IS
OUR WORLD WAR II.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU DISAGREE WITH
THE DETAILS OF THE GREEN NEW
DEAL SHE'S PROPOSING, BANNING
CARS AND AIRPLANES.
SHUTTING DOWN THE ENTIRE
AMERICAN ENERGY SECTOR,
REBUILDING EVERY DWELLING IN THE
UNITED STATES.
YOU CAN DISAGREE WITH THAT.
WHAT YOU CAN'T QUESTION IS
OCASIO-CORTEZ'S SINCERITY WHEN
SHE TALKS ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE,
CLEARLY, SHE REALLY MEANS IT.
OR DOES SHE?
THIS IS A MAN CALLED SIDECATING
BARTY, HER CHIEF OF STAFF.
IN THE INTERVIEW, HE MADE A
STUNNING ADMISSION THAT ALL OF
THAT STUFF ABOUT THE WORLD
ENDING, 12 YEARS TO SAVE THE
PLANET?
IT WAS ALL A LIE.
HE IS NOT WORRIED ABOUT
HUMANITY'S DEMISE, THE GREEN NEW
DEAL HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THAT.
HERE'S WHAT HE TOLD THE PAPER,
QUOTE, THE INTERESTING THING
ABOUT THE GREEN NEW DEAL IT
WASN'T ORIGINALLY A CLIMATE
THING AT ALL.
DO YOU THINK OF IT AS CLIMATE
THING?
WE THINK OF IT AS HOW DO YOU
CHANGE THE ENTIRE ECONOMY THING,
END QUOTE.
THAT'S ABOUT AS DIRECT AS IT
COULD BE.
NOT DESIGNED TO SAVE THE WORLD,
THOUGHT ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT AT
ALL.
IT'S ABOUT POWER.
HE AND OWE SASSO CORTEZ WANT
CONTROL HAVE THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
THEY WENT LOOKING FOR A HOSTILE
TAKEOVER OF THE ECONOMY.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS SCARY.
IT'S REMARKABLE THEY ARE
ADMITTING BUT SHOULDN'T RJ BE
SURPRISED IT HAPPENS.
MANUFACTURING CRISES IS THE LESS
PREFERRED WAY TO EXERT CONTROL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
A DECADE AGO ONLY WITH A CO-S IN
BED SHEETS WERE CALLED RACIST.
DURING THE LAST ELECTION, DONALD
TRUMP WAS EE ANNOUNCED AS A
RACIST.
NOW NANCY POE LOWSIE AND JOE
BIDEN ARE BEING WRITTEN OFFS ON
RACIST.
THERE'S MUCH LESS RACISM THAN
THERE USED TO BE.
WHAT CHANGED IS THE LEFT
REALIZED THEY COULD CREATE
BOOGIEMEN, FEAR-MONGERING, STUP
FIE THE MASSES AND BY THE TIME
YOU HAVE RECOVERED THEY'RE IN
CHARGE.
ROBERT HOCKET ADVISED OCASIO KOR
CORTEZ, AND A PROFESSOR.
YOU CAN SEE HOW WE'RE BETRAYED,
SCAMMED, THEY'RE ADMITTING
OCASIO-CORTEZ'S OFFICE, THAT THE
GREEN NEW DEAL ISN'T ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE OR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
IT'S ABOUT ECONOMIC CONTROL.
WHY SHOULD WE BE SHOCKED?
>> A FEW THINGS.
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING IT'S
COMBINED, RIGHT, ENVIRONMENTAL
CLEANUP ON THE ONE HAND AND
MODERNIZATION OF THE CLIMATE.
IT'S NOT MEANT TO BE A TAKEOVER,
IT'S A CONTINUATION OF WHAT
HISTORICALLY HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
GREAT PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON THE ONE
HAND AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR THAT
MAKES UP OUR ECONOMY ON THE
OTHER HAND.
>> Tucker: THE MOST VIBRANT
SECTOR IN THE AMERICAN ECONOMY
IS THE ENERGY SECTOR, THE GREEN
NEW DEAL WOULD ELIMINATE IT,
LITERALLY ELIMINATE IT, ACTUALLY
NOT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S WHAT IT SAYS.
I BELIEVE WE DEBATED THIS
BEFORE.
>> IT WOULD UPGRADE IT, YES,
UPGRADE IT.
THE IDEA IS TO GO TO NEUTRALITY.
>> Tucker: UPGRADE IT --
>> ADVANCED ECONOMY.
>> Tucker: INDEPENDENT IT.
>> THE OTHER ADVANCED ECONOMIES
ARE GRADUALLY TRANSITIONING AWAY
FROM CARBON BASED ENERGY.
WE'LL JOIN WITH THE THEM OF THEM
IN DOING IT.
WE'RE LAGGING BEHIND.
>> Tucker: NOW I'M DOUBLY
CONFUSED.
YOU'RE SAYING IT IS ABOUT
CLIMATE, BUT HE IS THE GUY WHO
OVERSAW THE WRITING OF IT SAYS
IT REALLY ISN'T.
THAT'S JUST A PRETEXT.
>> I THINK YOU'RE FICTION
FIXATING ON ONE SENTENCE.
>> Tucker: DEFINITELY FIXATING.
>> ALL THAT'S INVOLVED IN THE
GREEN NEW DEAL PROJECT, ALL
ALONG, THEY HAVE THOUGHT OF IT
AS A MASSIVE UPGRADE OF AMERICAN
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BRING US INTO
THE 21st CENTURY.
THAT WILL BE A GREENFICATION,
THERE ISN'T ANY NEW STRUK THAT
ISN'T GREEN.
IF YOU ARE STATEMENT OF THE ART,
YOU ARE GREEN.
WE DON'T MAKE KOR BAN BASED
INFRASTRUCTURE ANY MORE.
>> Tucker: WHAT THIS IS -- OKAY.
SO THE EFFECT OF THIS IS TO
ALLOW PEOPLE LIKE YOU AND HIM
AND OTHERS ELECTED,
OCASIO-CORTEZ JUST ELECTED 20
MINUTES AGO, WHO HAVE AN AMAZING
AMOUNT OF CONTROL ORE THE WAY
THE REST OF US LIVE.
>> NO, NO, NO.
>> Tucker: YOU GHAET CONTROL BY
SCARING THE HELL OUT OF US.
>> THERE'S NO DESIRE -- THERE'S
NO DESIRE FOR CONTROL.
IT'S ABOUT FACILITATION,
BRINGING FINANCE THAT IS
AVAILABLE.
CHUCKLE ALL YOU LIKE BUT IT IS
THE CASE.
>> Tucker: IT IS ALL ABOUT
CONTROL, THAT'S THE LAW.
>> NO, THIS IS --
>> Tucker: TELLING PEOPLE WHAT
TO DO.
>> IT'S A RESOLUTION, IT'S A
RESOLUTION CALLING FOR A SET OF
PROGRAMS TO TRANSITION THE
ECONOMY INTO A STATEMENT OF THE
ART GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE
ECONOMY.
THIS IS WHAT OTHER COUNTRIES
HAVE DONE ALREADY.
THIS IS WHY CHINA IS EATING OUR
LUNCH.
>> Tucker: USE ALL OF THE
EUPHEMISMS YOU WANT.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> Tucker: THIS IS ABOUT
FORCE --
>> NO, NO, LOOK AT WHAT CHINA IS
DOING.
CHINA NOW PRODUCES AND CONSUMES
BY FAR THE GREATER MART OF SOLAR
ENERGY PANELS.
ALL OF THOSE PHOTOVOLTAIC
PANELS.
WE USED TO BE THE PRINCIPLE
MANUFACTURER OF IT.
WE WERE THE PRINCIPLE EXPORTING
OF IT.
WE JUST GAVE THAT TO CHINA.
WE HAVE GIVEN HIGH SPEED RAIL TO
CHINA.
>> Tucker: I'M SORRY, LET ME --
>> AND THE DIFFERENT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE RIGHT CHINA
HAS RIPPED OFF OUR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY.
>> WE GAVE IT TO THEM.
>> Tucker: YOU SAY IT'S NOT
ABOUT CONTROL, IT'S VOLUNTARY.
>> NO, WELL, IT'S NOT
VOLUNTARY, IT'S FACILITATION.
THE IDEA IS TO HELP --
>> Tucker: THEN YOU POINT TO
CHINA, TO THE FASCIST GOVERNMENT
OF CHINA, AS AN EXAMPLE OF A
PROGRAM THAT YOU ADMIRE.
>> NO, WHAT YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND, I'M NOT SAYING I
ADMIRE CHINA.
THE GOVERNMENT AIDS CHINESE
INDUSTRY.
OUR GOVERNMENT DOES NOT AID
AMERICAN INDUSTRY.
>> Tucker: NOW I'M WITH YOU ON
THAT.
>> GOOD.
THE THING IS I HAVE BEEN
THINKING ALL ALONG THAT YOU AND
I AND THE REST OF RUSS ACTUALLY
ON THE SAME TEAM.
THERE'S JUST A LOT OF
MISUNDERSTANDING WHAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO ADVOCATE.
>> Tucker: I'LL TELL YOU WHY,
YOU ALL USE -- OKAY.
>> MANY OF YOUR RECENT --
>> Tucker: USING CLIMATE CHANGE
AS A WAY TO TERRIFY THE PUBLIC.
>> NO, NO, IT ISN'T.
>> Tucker: YES YOU ARE.
>> IT IS URGENT.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO TERRIFY
ANYBODY.
WE'RE TRYING TO CONVINCE PEOPLE
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS RESTORE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
GOVERNMENT AND INDUSTRY TO
FACILITATE BETTER FINANCING OF
THE STATE OF THE ART GREEN
STRUK.
WE WANT TO BE THE --
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE WANT TO BE THE MOST MODERN
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE WORLD,
FASTEST GROWING ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD.
WE USED TO DO THAT, HAVING THE
GOVERNMENT COLLABORATE WITH
BUSINESS.
WE DON'T DO THAT NEW.
>> Tucker: PART OF THAT IS
RIGHT, PART OF IT IS DISHONEST.
>> NO, IT IS THE CASE.